on fait simplement un constat on se
constate que le ponton de la première
édition en 2015 avec un budget
qui avoisine les 480 mille euros on
arrive en 2018 avec un événement qui a
fait ses preuves qui a eu un
retentissement mondial
énorme donc et se hisse parmi le sommet
de ce qui existe pour des manifestations
de ce type et que en 2018
on subit déjà après nos pleurs après
l'événement une diminution de budget de
50% et que pour 2019 les réengagements
seraient sur la même base que 2010 donc
50% en moins donc ni région de budget du
budget en fait en quatre années de 50%
ce qui fait que en fait l'opération
entre plus dans dans le budget
prévisionnel que que tu as établie